uk residents who are fully vaccinated
through the uk vaccine rollout will no
longer
have to self-isolate when they return to
england
they'll still be required uh to take
three-day a test three days before
returning the pre-departure test
demonstrating the negative before they
travel
and a pcr test on or before day two but
they will no
longer be required to take a day eight
test in essence
this means that for fully vaccinated
travelers the requirements for green
and amber-less countries are the same
to be clear a full vaccination means 14
days have passed
since your final dose of the vaccine and
it's also important to note
that health ministers or health matters
are devolved
so decision making and implementation
may differ
across uk administrations and we'll
continue to work
with the devolved administrations to
ensure we achieve
our shared objectives of safe
sustainable robust return to
international travel
madam deputy speaker the change i'm
announcing today
will prioritize those vaccinated in the
united
kingdom however as i made clear last
week we want to
welcome international visitors back to
the uk and are working to extend
our approach to vaccinated passengers
from important markets and
holiday destinations later this summer
such as the united states
and the eu and i'll update the house and
due course on how we
approach vaccinated individuals from
other countries
when i highlighted the potential policy
to the house last week i
explained that we needed to take some
additional time to look at
how children and the evidence around
children who will not of course
have been able to benefit from vaccines
will be treated
i can tell the house today that children
under 18
returning from amber list countries will
not
have to isolate on the return term nor
take
a day eight tests children between the
ages of five and ten will only need to
take
a day two tests and before and as before
children four and under will be exempt
from all testing
and isolation requirements i know this
was a big concern of families and after
working with
scientists and public health experts i'm
delighted to be able to offer
that reassurance today the success of
our vaccine program
has been aided by those selflessly
creating the great benefits for society
in the rest of the world by being a part
of those clinical trials without which
we wouldn't have this vaccine program
we're committed to ensuring that they
are not disadvantaged
as a result of being part of those
trials and i'm delighted to announce
that those on approved clinical trials
in the uk
will also not need to self isolate
isolate or take that day
test from an ambulance country
passengers should of course check with
the foreign office travel advice to
understand the latest entry
requirements and covert 19 rules at
their
destination madam deputy speaker we
know that travel is important that many
people have not been able to travel
of course for the last year and a half
this is not just of course about
holidays
eager as we are i'm sure the time in the
sun but this is also about reuniting
families
who've been apart throughout this
pandemic it's about helping businesses
to trade and grow and it's about
supporting aviation a sector which
hundreds of thousands of jobs
rely on an industry which this
government has backed
through seven billion pounds of support
through this pandemic
and as the industry tell me the support
is of course very welcome
but the only way to actually recover is
to allow them
to fly and for travel to resume again
which is why i'm pleased to also
announce today that from the 19th of
july
will remove the guidance that people
should not
travel to countries on the amber list
and this means that people will be able
to travel for leisure for business
and see family to amber list countries
i'm sure the whole house will welcome
this development
approach uh to international travel
however i want to be clear
that as we begin to ease restrictions
travel will not be the same as it was
before
in say 2019. people should continue to
check foreign office travel advice
travel where possible outside of busy
weekend times and importantly
they should expect that their experience
at the border will of course be
different because longer
waiting times will be necessitated by
risks even as we
introduce and expand the range of
e-gates
available to read the passenger locator
forms
i must also make clear that public
health remains our key
priority and that's why we'll not make
any changes to requirements applying
to those arriving from countries on the
red
list even where they are fully
vaccinated